un dimanche de gala au stade léo
lagrange des mureaux avec un derby
yvelinois le fcm 9e de national 3
recevait l'équipe réserve du paris
saint-germain troisième on est rentré
timidement et nous ont vraiment ils ont
vraiment acculés sur notre défense nous
aurons très bien dedans c'est peut-être
ce qui nous a réveillés et suivi d'un
but donc c'est à ce moment là on s'est
réveillés on a été plus agressif on est
restés plus à distance d'intervention
par rapport aux joueurs mauvaise entame
de match pour les rouge et bleu et un
but concédé à la 12e minute les
muriautin réagissant suite avec tout
d'abord deux grosses occasions
avant l'égalisation à la 38e minute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non j'ai pas peur parce que si ça avait
été en début de saison oui mais là je
connais l'état d'esprit de mon équipe on
est bien physiquement on est bien on est
capable de marquer à tous les matchs là
où il fallait jouer c'est surtout quand
le psg n'avait pas le ballon là on
voyait que les trois attaquants ne
revenait pas des fonds des ctc brèche là
qu'il faut l'exploiter et c'est pour ça
que j'ai demandé à mes excentré de bien
animer le couloir au retour des
vestiaires le fcm impose la même
intensité et pousse le gardien parisien
à l'erreur
[Applaudissements]
pour ces que ses équipes allaient aimer
avec le ballon que nous mais nous on
avait
mais nous nous n'avait on avait la dalle
on avait faim on avait faim de gagner ce
match prend une revanche on a perdu 2 0
là bas a pris un rouge etc du coup on
avait faim on a sué tranchant et ça a
payé à un quart d'heure du terme
l'équipe fait le break 3 ça sera le
score final
relégable depuis début décembre le fc
les murs au point qu'aujourd'hui à la
huitième position et n'a plus perdu à
domicile depuis le 7 novembre c'est
surtout de rectifier les choses c'est
une équipe à l'aller pj nous avaient
battus 2-0 là aujourd'hui on est capable
de leur en mettre 3 la semaine prochaine
on reçoit créteil qui nous en avait
quand même passé 4 aussi cesser des
matchs à leur goût doit être capable
aussi de rétablir que ce qu'on avait
fait à l'aller c'était des accidents et
aujourd'hui chez eux ils nous ont fait
du mal nous on le rend coup pour coup
même si l'objectif premier du club reste
le maintien à neuf journées de la fin
les joueurs ne l'entendent pas de cette
oreille
on sait que pour monter ça va être très
difficile mais finir dans le top 5 ce
serait magnifique à la prochaine journée
le fcm reste à la maison avec la
réception de l'équipe b de l'us créteil
lusitanos